wir streiten hier heute Abend über den
Zustand der Ampelkoalition und vor allen
Dingen über das hier was bei mir auf dem
Tisch liegt nämlich das neue
heizungsgesetz aus dem Hause von Robert
Habeck aus dem Wirtschaftsministerium
bei uns der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der FDP unter anderem
Johannes Vogel haben Sie bei diesem
Gesetz wenn sie jetzt gegenüber sitzen
würden all denen die in Häuschen haben
auch eine ältere heute Heizung haben
richtig gutes Gewissen ich ist wir haben
ja im ersten Teil der Sendung schon
drüber gesprochen es ist ähm sie hat
sich fundamental verändert zum ersten
Entwurf und das war nötig keine
austauschpflichten
technologieoffenheit bei auch Neueinbau
von heizen wir haben die gemeinsamen
Verantwortung dass unser Land bis Mitte
des jahrhundert im Gesetz und ich glaube
es kann ein gutes Gesetz werden aber es
ist ja gerade das Gewissen das ist ja
schon nicht ganz ohne einen guten
gesetzt habe ich am Ende natürlich auch
ein gutes Gewissen
apropos gutes Gewissen in den nächsten
Tagen kommt ein roter Knopf ins Spiel
der nicht ganz unwichtig ist für die
Zukunft möglicherweise auch Energie
zukünft in Deutschland das ist ja der
rote Knopf der im Kernkraftwerk Isa 2
sich befindet
Mitte dieses Monats also tatsächlich nur
noch ein paar Tage hin wird auf diesen
Knopf gedrückt in der Nacht um 23:30 Uhr
etwa und dann ist Schluss mit der
Atomkraft in Deutschland haben Sie bei
dieser Entscheidung gutes Gewissen nein
das halte ich ähm für wirklich falsch
und das habe ich auch schon mehrfach
öffentlich gesagt ich glaube dass wir
genau falsch rum aus Kernkraft und
Kohlekraft aussteigen und jedes
Kernkraftwerk was uns auf dem Weg zu zur
vollen dekarbonisierung ich glaube auch
zu einer Welt wo wir mit Erneuerbaren
noch viel mehr machen können mit
Speicher Wasserstoff jedes kann
Kraftwerk was wir auf dem Weg dahin
früher ausschalten als ein
Kohlekraftwerk ist ein Kohlekraftwerk
mehr als wir bräuchten und das halte ich
für ganz fasten
war die einzige Regierung angehört sie
haben die Laufzeit ja auch vorübergehend
jetzt verlängert das heißt so wenn man
eine Regierung angehört die genau das
jetzt verantwortlich diesen Knopf zu
drücken und eben nicht die Laufzeiten zu
verlängern könnten sie ruhig schlafen
also die Beschlüsse dazu sind vor genau
12 Jahren jetzt genau vor 12 vor zwölf
Jahren gefasst worden in einer Union von
fdp-regierung mit damals noch unserem
guten Freund Westerwelle mit
Brüderle und dann mit der Philipp Rösler
als Wirtschaftsminister und uns ich habe
intern als einer der fünf Fachminister
die für diesen keine Energieausstoß
ausstieg und Energie in die zuständig
waren wegen Gebäude und wegen Energien
der Mobilität intern immer massiv
dagegen davor gewarnt so schnell aus der
gerne Energie auszusteigen mit allen
Folgen die das ganze hat jetzt haben wir
die Folgen alle die sind damals negiert
worden ich musste dass es
Kabinettsmitglied mittragen die FDP hat
es auch mitgetragen damals aber es wir
haben trotzdem die Freiheit heute zu
sagen es war falsch wir hätten das nicht
tun dürfen ich gebe Ihnen da vollkommen
Recht herr Vogel aber jetzt haben wir
den Mist jetzt müssen wir irgendwie
vernünftig damit umgehen und dass die am
15 April jetzt herausgehen die letzten
drei nimmt natürlich in der Grundlast
etwas weg was wir dringend brauchen
können könnten auch um die Energiepreise
die Strompreise insgesamt
zu verzweifelt die gehen nicht in die
Arbeitslosigkeit die bauen aber ihr
Kernkraftwerk jetzt zurück und die sagen
in diesen Tagen hier zerstören hier was
was komplett funktioniert wir schicken
in 50-Jährigen gesunden 50-Jährigen
sagen sie mit Blick auf ihr
Kernkraftwerk einfach in rennt ich finde
die Betroffenen Schicksale schlimm ich
habe in dem Beitrag natürlich gelesen
und das hat mich schon berührt wir sind
die Schicksale meinte die dort arbeiten
oder meinen Sie uns alle meine ich nicht
nein nein ich meine die Leute die dort
arbeiten und natürlich fiel uns jetzt
etwas an Grundlast also das müssen wir
nicht abhängig von von Wind und und von
Sonne oder so und wir bräuchten nicht so
viel kohleverstromen und wir müssen oder
oder Kohle wieder ans Netz gehen lassen
und wir müssen kein Gas verstrom aber
mal ganz ehrlich das ist vergossene
Milch das ist jetzt einfach durch ja der
Körper
den brauchst den Knopf nicht drücken der
Knopf ist in der Form gedrückt dass wir
jetzt keine Brennstäbe so schnell
bekommen dass die Dinger müssten jetzt
in jedem Fall vom Netz das ist durch du
kannst jetzt ein paar Monate stehen
lassen und dann kannst du sie wieder
hochfahren genau
vier vielleicht fünf Monate da könnten
sie wieder zu das kostet ein paar
Monaten sagen müssen dann dann wäre es
vielleicht na ich glaube mich dass es
etwas geändert hätte aber ich hätte noch
einen anderen Vorschlag das ist jetzt
vergossene Milch der Atomausstieg ist
ist beschlossen und das was Teile der
Union jetzt wollen Neubau von
Kernkraftwerken in Deutschland würde uns
für eine so starke gesellschaftliche
Spaltung stehen und für eine so starke
Debatte das ist kein Thema mehr aber
eins sollte man schon machen und da
verstehe ich wieder Herrn zärgerichte
aber wenn man sich so technologisch
immer so festlegt man kann natürlich
weiter der Atomkraft weiter forschen und
sie weiterentwickeln denn das ist doch
was wir heute an Atomkraft haben ist
doch nicht der letzte Stand der
menschlichen Entwicklung
zu solchen Entscheidungen führt nein das
ist nuklearte wie die zu solchen
Entscheidungen führt wie der von ihnen
gerade Ideologie Ideologie natürlich ist
es Ideologie ich habe auch ein ca in dem
Buch nicht verstanden dass er gesagt hat
die Leute brauchen Sicherheit die Leute
müssen wissen dass sie künftig eine
Wärmepumpe brauchen
CO2 mehr imitieren dürfen wie sie das
machen und da bin ich bei Herrn Vogel
das musst du doch den Leuten überlassen
Ideologie steht im Raum sind sie mit der
Deutschen Umwelthilfe die ja sehr
präsent war auch mit Blick auf die
Automobilindustrie sind sie gemeinnützig
ja selbstverständlich und verstehen mit
beiden Füßen auf dem Boden der
Wissenschaft und im übrigens auch der
Energiewirtschaft da würde ich Ihnen
empfehlen mal eine Umfrage zu machen
unter deutschen Energiemanager werden
sie niemanden finden der tatsächlich
dafür ist die Atom Energie geben
den Begriff aus dem Vereinsrecht aus dem
Unternehmensrecht sozusagen sie
bezeichnen sich als gemeinnützig wem
nützen sie ja wir mit unserer Arbeit
treten wir für den Schutz unserer
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen ein wir
treten auch für Verbraucherrechte ein
das ist ein zweiter ganz wichtiger Teil
unserer Arbeit und selbstverständlich
was wir tun dient eben am Ende
bezahlbaren Energiepreisen dient einer
sicheren Energieversorgung dient der
Einhaltung der Klimaziele und dient auch
dem Schutz unserer Lebensgrundlage
und da orientieren wir uns streng an und
Fakten gemeinnützig also was jetzt
gesagt das war der schöne aufgesagt da
muss ich wirklich sagen natürlich müssen
sie das begründen können also mir ist
die Deutsche Umwelthilfe schon oft genug
querver dann ausgegelegen und sie
berufen sich auch Wissenschaft wissen
Sie ich habe ich habe lange es Assistent
und zwei Universitäten gearbeitet im
tierische Forschung wissenschaftlich auf
und ab und habe gelernt wie man
Wissenschaft fälschen kann bis zum geht
nicht mehr
ja wie sie sich auf Wissenschaft oft
schon berufen haben
naja glauben Sie es ruhig aber das ist
natürlich einseitig und wenn sie mir mit
fünf Professoren kommen dann komme ich
in die mit zehn Professoren mit der
Wissenschaft
ich hätte ihre Organisation die
Gemeinnützigkeit im Übrigen schon
längster abgesprochen und vor allen
Dingen die man wissen was sie betreiben
müssen kurze Frage ganz kurze Antwort
musst Wirtschaftsministerium eigentlich
gemeinnützig sein also uns allen nutzen
ja natürlich dass du die Aufgabe von so
Ministerium auch nicht drüber reden ich
frage deswegen nach weil in diesen
Stunden in diesen Tagen diese Grafik
wieder einmal durchs Internet geht da
sind einige Positionen aufgeführt im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium von Robert
Habeck da sehen sie ganz rechts Michael
Kellner der kommt aus der grünen Partei
hat er den Bundestagswahlkampf auch
organisiert erst mittlerweile
Staatssekretär und er ist verheiratet
mit Verena gleichen das ist bei weitem
keine Sünde Verena greifen aber ist die
Schwester von Patrick reichen und der
ist auch Staatssekretär im
Wirtschaftsministerium Verena greifen
wiederum ist im Ökoinstitut tätig genau
wie ihr anderer Bruder Jakob reichen ist
das ein Netzwerk Herr Ramsauer reguliert
man so ist das normal nein normales das
nicht wenn das Ganze unter einer
Unionsregierung wäre dann würde es
heißen Nepotismus Vettern Wirtschaft
Verfilzung
unmögliche Netzwerke aber da gibt es
leider durch aber ich muss ja noch mal
auch Sie zurückkommen herum aber sie
haben gerade eben davon berichtet wie
ähm an ihren wissenschaftlichen
Instituten an den Sie gearbeitet haben
Wissenschaft gefälscht worden und das
finde ich jetzt schon auch noch mal ein
Vorbild in unserer Richtung auf den ich
da eingehen möchte was wir tun ist dass
wir uns an uns zweifelhaften
wissenschaftlichen Grundlagen
orientieren der weltklimaat IPC auch
eine beratungsgreminister auch für die
Bundesregierung gibt und da muss man
sich schon die Mühe machen über Fakten
sich genau zu informieren und da will
ich noch mal konkret zurückkommen was
wir gerade eben Einstiegs über die
Atomkraft diskutiert haben es stimmt ja
nicht dass die Atomenergie die billigste
Energieform wäre wie sie das gerade
behauptet haben sondern im Gegenteil
gesehen
wo Subventionen Atomkraftwerke in
Großbritannien in Finnland sie durften
sich einmal wären sie durften sich
einmal werden an der Stelle und möchte
trotzdem noch mal auf das Netzwerk zu
sprechen kommen wie würden sie das
bezeichnen Ramsauer sagt das ist
Vetternwirtschaft was wir da sehen Sie
ich finde dass da die Union die letzte
Partei ist die sich weit aus dem Fenster
lehnen können auf der anderen Seite ganz
ohne Union das wir im
Wirtschaftsministerium eine unheimliche
Verbesserung von Kompetenz jetzt
beobachtet haben wir haben im Gegensatz
zu den vorherigen Jahren und auch den
Zeiten unter der Union jetzt
ausgewiesene Energiefachleute dass die
sich untereinander kennen die sind nicht
verwerflich sind verwandt und
verheiratet Bruder Ehemann ich habe
jetzt nicht gehört dass Herr Kellner und
Herren verheiratet sind da möchte ich
auch niemanden emotional zu Natrium
meine beobachtet meine Beobachtung meine
Beobachtung ist dort dass es da
exzellente Experten gibt mit denen sind
wir weiß Gott nicht immer einverstanden
und haben wir eine ganze Menge Streit
aber ich kann nicht beobachten dass da
wenn sie sich das anschauen wie gesagt
hier darf jeder mit jedem verheiratet
sein wie man das mag und es gibt
sicherlich auch in anderen Ministerien
in Interessenkonfliktes mal gut die zu
kennen wer da möglicherweise mit wem
verwandt verschwiegert ist und wer wie
in welche Position gekommen sind wussten
sie das wussten sie diese Verbindung
kannten sie die ich habe die Grafik
jetzt eben das erste mal gesehen und
konnte sie mir auch jetzt also auf der
Basis ich kann jetzt hier auf dem Schirm
irgendwie eine Grafik schaue ich mir
gerne noch mal hin also ich gucke ich
mir gerne mal im Nachgang ausführlich an
die würden sie das nennen Vätern wird
Wirtschaft oder ist das was ja völlig
ohne dich gar nicht wie wer jetzt wo im
Verhältnis steht hier sind zwei
Staatssekretärinnen
hier gibt's eine Ehre
dem Urteil zu kommen ich sei es nur eins
es gibt in Deutschland das
Ressortprinzip und jeder Minister und
jede Ministerin ist verantwortlich für
die Organisation seines oder ihres
Hauses und ich messe auch die Minister
dieser Bundesregierung an ihren
Ergebnissen Punkt herr Vogel allerletzte
Frage weil wir so zusammensitzen heute
geht es rauf und runter um die Kinder
Grundsicherung ganz kurzes Wort dazu
kommt die oder kommt die nicht eine gute
kommt aber einfach mal mehr Geld fordern
wie das die Familienministerin macht
überzeugt mich nicht sondern was er
dafür sorgen müssen ist dass die
Leistung die wir haben dass die mal
zusammengefasst werden einfacher gemacht
werden und das Familien den Sie
zuständigen Sie nutzen können und da
warte ich auf einen Vorschlag ein
Konzept der Familienministerin was sie
bis heute schuldig bleibt danke für
diese Diskussionen danke
Ihnen für die lebhafte Diskussion wir
sind zurück nächste Woche hier bei Bild
danke ihnen würden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie